hey guys it's max in this video we are
going to be taking a look at the new
homepod minis
and comparing them to the homepod mainly
in terms of sound
quality now i got these in a couple days
ago we've been working on mac videos
but i've been so excited and so tempted
to open these guys up and take a look
the crazy thing is that they're 99 for
one
compared to 300 bucks for a single home
pod
now those of you guys that have heard
the homepod you know that it sounds
amazing the bass is great
it gets surprisingly loud we'll be
comparing the sound quality with a
variety of different
songs and music and along with that
we're gonna pair these two together
and listen if a stereo pair for 200
sounds better or maybe gets louder than
the homepod
all right my first impression this thing
is tiny i know i did the math on it i
saw how small it's gonna be
but it is crazy now with that actually
has
a good feel in the hand the material
feels the same as the homepod
but it doesn't feel too lightweight
which i was concerned about
now this braided cable feels really nice
as well
we have usbc on this end and in the box
we have a fast charger for an iphone so
some of you guys if you need to fast
charge your phone you might unplug your
homepod mini
and plug in your iphone now i will say
it is really weird that they just use
the regular white one
for the black homepod minis so let's go
ahead and plug this thing in
a few seconds passed and now we have a
light right away you guys see that
we have a pop-up to set up the homepod
mini all right we gotta
take a photo of it bam
all right we're all set up now before i
do the comparison let's just get my
first impressions
and hear the homepod mini by itself i
have our classic song playing here that
you guys have heard a million times in
our videos
[Music]
it's not it's not maxed out yet
[Music]
the base is deeper than i expected
i actually i just got in the new echoes
couple of them the round ones so far
this sounds so much better than that 50
one
okay let's let's turn it all the way up
[Music]
[Music]
here
[Music]
okay what do you think vadim
so i have a couple thoughts right away
first off
the bass is way better than i expected i
thought
that the bass is where this speaker was
going to lack
now the vocals don't sound as sharp as i
expected i guess
i thought they would tune it a little
bit differently now this just has one
single
speaker it doesn't have separate
tweeters and a woofer like the homepod
does
so as far as volume it's about where i
expected
now i'm going to be doing another video
comparing this to the 50
echo and then the 100 echo and then the
nest the new google nest audio speaker
make sure you guys are subscribed if you
want to see that video let's go ahead
and set this up
and i'm going to play through with both
of these and you guys can take a listen
to how they compare with this song
before we switch to another genre
[Music]
study
all right guys let me know your thoughts
down in the comment section
below we are actually recording with a
pro
microphone that's about five feet away
of course i'll give you guys my opinions
now
first off the sound quality difference
isn't as
great as i expected the biggest surprise
is the bass
the bass sounds really full and rich
just like the homepod does
there are differences on the high end
the homepod has a bunch of tweeters
all around and then a main woofer we'll
put up how much it has right over here
now the homepod mini has just
one speaker and then it has two
radiators that
aren't technically speakers they just
make the bass sound better
so that makes sense why the bass in here
is
so great for a speaker of this size
overall i'm just shocked by how close
the sound quality is
the biggest difference that everybody
will notice is loudness now i checked on
my apple watch as far as the peak
decibels and it looks like there's about
three to four decibels higher
loudness or volume with the standard
homepod and in reality
it's a big difference when you're just
hearing it for yourself i think moving
forward for the rest of the sound
comparisons i'm gonna use
both of these because i want to see how
much better and how much louder it makes
when you have two of them they're still
100
less than the home pod now i think if
you want a home pod
for just background music at quiet
volumes
you're going to be extremely happy with
how this sounds it is way closer than i
expected if you want really loud music
if you want to
dance if you want to just fill a whole
large room the homepod
regular one is going to be better but
now let's go ahead and set these up i'm
gonna switch the song
and we'll compare the sound quality with
a stereo pair
[Music]
is
[Laughter]
all right guys once again let me know
your thoughts down in the comments
section
and i have to say this is very
interesting for a couple of reasons
the first test we did um the sound
quality difference
it wasn't that drastic i noticed that
the highs were lacking in the homepod
the mini one
but other than that it just sounded like
a quieter version overall
this time listening to that rock song
wow
the homepod killed the minis
the mids the quality there the bass when
you have all those layers of different
instruments it's a lot more complex
it sounds so much better now of course
having two of these
the volume did go up but it's still not
as loud as
a single home pod there's about one to
two decibels difference
peak and let's do one more track of
course all these are no copyright or
else this video could get flagged
um but i have a classical song a little
with a little bit of a twist on there
let's go ahead and make sure you have
headphones on and let's compare these
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
all right guys the results are getting
more interesting as we move forward
of course let me know your thoughts down
below
first off the volume difference wasn't
as big
in this track at least to my ears maybe
you guys will hear
otherwise and the sound quality
difference there
was much much smaller than the previous
rock song now there's a couple things i
noticed now the homepod
the high hats the very highest notes i
could tell
they stood out a little bit more than
the homepod minis
in stereo pair and then the biggest
difference the most noticeable one is
there's a couple of the low notes there
where it digs the deepest
that the homepod minis just could not
hit now
the other bass in the song i was
surprised it sounded pretty close it
wasn't as
strong of bass but the notes they
sounded good
i was really surprised by the mids and
the highs there other than the very high
size but if you didn't have a homepod
there you wouldn't miss it
if you're going to listen to simpler
songs maybe some edm with some vocals
and then some bassy instruments
you don't care about the lowest notes
that the homepod can hit
i would maybe just go with a couple
minis you're gonna save a hundred bucks
especially if you want to spread them
out in a stereo pair
now if you want the ultimate sound
quality definitely the homepod is better
than these two it's a little bit louder
and especially if you're listening to
really complex music with a lot of
instruments a lot of mids
highs like the different rock tracks
where there's so much there
you get a lot more definition from the
homepod
with that said i guess with my final
conclusion i'm really impressed by how
good
these sound for the size we shouldn't be
really doing this comparison it should
just be
you know yeah this is way bigger way
more expensive it's going to sound
better
and i really can't wait to compare this
to what amazon and google has to offer
because
i think we're going to be really
surprised so click that circle above if
you guys want to see
that video and enable those
notifications and we have a couple
other great videos right over there
thank you guys for watching this been
max and i will see you
in the next video
[Music]